my wife and i laila talk to 10 to 20
service information e-learning coaching
businesses per week that we're looking
to invest in and that's you know after
they've gone through uh you know several
screening processes and what i wanted to
talk about today is what are the ways
that we think through in terms of the
value of the business and not from a
dollar's perspective but like what is
the opportunity and i want to give you
kind of the three-step checklist that i
think through and how you can apply it
to your own business and think like how
can i take what i'm currently doing and
make it more of an opportunity for me
and if you don't know who i am my name's
alex from rosie on acquisition.com it's
a portfolio of businesses it does right
now 110 million a year and i have
nothing to sell you so i make these
videos just because i was once broke and
i don't want you to be broke so that is
why we do this anyways so let's rock and
roll when you've heard people say
opportunity or opportunity vehicle you
need to get into a better monetization
structure there's different ways of kind
of saying the same thing which is like
how much money can we possibly make that
from this core thing and so when i'm
thinking through this there are three
pieces that i think through at the end
of the video i'm going to kind of walk
through kind of the the downstream
impacts of these things um and how you
can apply them but this is the this is
the big picture and you have to make
these i have to make lots of decisions
really quickly so i have to use
frameworks in order to make those
decisions right and make snap judgments
on like do i think this is interesting
should we pursue this further or do
should we just give some advice and you
know wish them well and maybe see them
in the future if they implement it right
there's three things that i that i've
kind of boiled down to an opportunity
vehicle is this something is this
something a business or opportunity that
i want to pursue and so for a lot of you
guys who are starting out this will be
very valuable for you because hopefully
you can just set this up right and if
you're already in the process of
building your business then maybe you
can make alterations to the business and
incorporate this so there's three things
that i'm looking at in terms of like
what i think makes something much more
interesting number one is the number of
potential units sold so a lot of times
people talk about tam total adjustable
market and i'll talk about why i think
that that the longer i do this is
somewhat of a misnomer um so i'll talk
about that at the end but just how many
people could potentially buy this thing
right or buy this service or buy this
you know whatever this thing is how many
people do i think would be a fit um to
be purchasers of the thing so that's
number one and that's just going to show
me how big how long we can run this game
is this indefinite is this like you know
i mean like if you're selling weight
loss like do i believe that people are
going to continue is food going to keep
chasing better and are people going to
be able to change their genetics in
terms of how they how they rely on it no
i think those things are things that
aren't going to change overall and so
those are assumptions that i'm willing
to base the fact that there's a lot of
people want to buy this thing it's just
a simple way of thinking through like
what are the assumptions that would
continue to make this trip so number one
is how many people could potentially buy
this service number two is going to be
what is the potential profit i can make
from the service all right and that's a
function of two things which is what is
the value that people are are getting
from this outcome and then how much does
it cost us to deliver it and so those
are two very important components
because there's some some elements right
that are extremely valuable but also
very costly to deliver so that's
something that i'd be less interested in
it might be very valuable but like
there's not a lot of opportunity for
profit on the flip side sometimes it's a
very very small amount of value but it
costs nothing right and the thing is is
there the gross profit is actually kind
of enticing and depending on what that
first one was which is how many people
are willing to buy this thing then it's
like ah this becomes a little bit more
interesting right and so the potential
for profit and the gross margin of the
of the unit of thing that we are selling
becomes more interesting which is why
laila and i in general like course
e-learning you know guru coaching type
businesses to work with because we can
transition them from a not valuable
model into a much more valuable
enterprise model that has something that
they could sell in the future if they
wanted to the third piece is the
competitive uh the supply demand or
competitive dynamics of the landscape
and so i'll give you a counter example
and and a good example so if i wanted to
get into wireless cell phones right like
or cell phone service well lots of
people need it okay that's good because
how much does it cost me to add one more
uh user to my phone phone network
pennies right and what do i charge them
hundreds of dollars a month but then the
third one is competitive dynamics well
i'd have to uh beat out verizon and any
tnt and all the other big
conglomerations of phone service that
exist it'd be very difficult for me to
break into that and so that's an example
of it checks two of the three boxes but
not the third one and so different
example of that i'll tell you like a
hypothetical crazy good example would be
if someone had figured out a way to
create hardware that does crypto mining
right and let's say that that crypto
mining you know could get could make
people
let's say 50 000 a year all right this
is i'm using an extreme example to
illustrate the point well if they had
figured that out then one just about
everybody wants you know passive or
close to passive side income so total
number of people that we can sell this
to a lot amount of value that someone's
getting a lot 50 000 and in this case
it's actually quantifiable how much does
it cost us in this instance we'd have to
figure out what the cost of the rig
would be but let's say it was you know
small let's say it was 500
well then this business becomes
incredibly interesting as an opportunity
and then the fourth or so the third is
what are the competitive dynamics well
if there's no one else who can offer
this then we're we're off to the races
right but on top of that how new is the
space are there a lot of new people
coming into it are there established
people who are killing it that would try
and price us out etc and in this space
for example everything's brand new and
so the competitive dynamics are great
and it's massive you know it's very
quickly growing and will continue to
grow probably for the first table so in
this instance it'd be like wow this is a
very interesting business that i would
want to participate in or learn more
about and so if you're thinking through
these lenses and i'll talk about the tam
thing in a second about why i don't
think it's necessarily as good as people
used to think in terms of assessing the
value of the business i'll talk about
that in a second but if you're using
these three lenses to think about your
own business you can ask yourself okay
is there a way that i could make this
you know applicable to potentially more
people so that i could have a total
higher number of units or bigger
audience that i could sell to number one
number two is is there a way that i can
reconfigure this thing so that it either
makes the the customer a more valuable
outcome and or it costs us less to
fulfill that outcome right so we
increase the gross profit per unit sold
is there a way that i can reconfigure
what i'm doing right and i'll give you a
couple rules rules of thumb here that i
like which is if i'm just doing any kind
of service business i like to have 80 or
higher gross margins all right so what
that means is if i'm selling something
for a thousand dollars a month it has to
cost me less than 200 a month and for
those of you who are new to making money
people will get their panties in a wad
about that but like profit is what
drives business all right it's not that
all of that gross profit that's before
cost of doing business goes to the owner
that's just everything that you have to
chip down away from so you're starting
at 80 and let's say you want to run a
business that runs 50 margins well then
that means you've got 30 percent there
right in that thousand dollar month
example i got 300 bucks a month to cover
everything else that i do in the
business that covers that covers
marketing that covers admin costs it
covers payroll that covers that uh that
covers you know hr finance all of these
other fun legal whatever all the other
functions of the business so the thing
is 80 is minimum and the thing is
especially smaller businesses think for
some reason that that that's like
charging more is bad right and you got
to get out of that because if you want
to help more people you need to have
gross profit in order to scale if you
look at the biggest companies that exist
out there they sell something that's
very valuable that costs them almost
nothing so think about google right they
sell ad space it costs them a moment
nothing besides the actual like their
incremental cost of running an ad is is
virtually zero right and they charge a
king's ransom for it right facebook same
thing right they charge for eyeballs
that cost that like they've one time
cost of building then after that the
incremental cost of of showing add some
more eyeballs is almost nothing so it's
all margin you look at the phone company
that i was i was explaining earlier they
have their one time cost of building the
thing but then the at the additional
cost of adding one more user is almost
insignificant right but they can still
charge a great amount of money for it
this is the reason software is something
that people find incredibly valuable it
costs one time to build it and then
after that the each incremental user is
almost all profit now the only other
type of business that's like this with a
close to 100 gross margin is information
and education businesses which is why
layla and i like these types of
businesses because they have uh they
have the same margin as software
businesses except you don't have the
cost of development the downside is that
those types of businesses tend to
have higher churn because the increased
value or the value declines over time
when someone learns a skill from this
type of business that being said there
are ways of reconfiguring the business
to increase the stick of the client with
by pulling out the things that are
consumable versus not versus one times
consumable um and i'm going into the
weeds here but hopefully you'll enjoy it
so something that's a one-time
consumption would be something where i
have now gotten the skill from the thing
or i've learned the learned the process
and this is especially true with
learning or elearning type businesses if
someone comes for a skill they learn the
skill and then the value of training for
the skill decreases because they already
have it duh that makes sense but the
thing is a lot of times when people are
learning something there are other
components that surround them that are
consumable on an ongoing basis so the
information is one time consumable as
long as they learn the skill but then
there become other things that are
consistently consumable so community is
consumable as in like i want access to
it this month i want access to it next
month accountability is consumable i
consumed it this month to get to point b
but now i want to consume it again to
get to point c
an additional piece would be if the the
type of skill that you're teaching
someone creates new problems which most
times if you're good at teaching
something all problems create solutions
or all solutions create more problems
right and so when we solve the the old
problems we get new ones and that's why
we as business owners should always just
see problems as blank checks for us to
cash in at our own desire right there
are problems everywhere and they just
have a dollar amount attached to them
and the question is do we want to go and
cash that check in and solve that
problem right like that's how you can
you can perceive problems in the world
in terms of opportunity for these types
of business which is why we like them is
that we can pull these pieces out and
then create something that has really
high margin and has high ltv and
continues to build enterprise value over
time by selecting and peeling these
pieces apart and so finally i want to
talk about why i think tam is not as
good of a you know indicator for the
potential size of a company well look at
some of these original companies so look
at facebook when they started out it was
like supposed to just be a college you
know network thing right it was supposed
to be you know facebook i think is what
the actual term was way back in the day
uh for like a yearbook right and so
that's literally what the name of the
thing was right and so somebody might
look at that initially obviously people
could see where it could potentially go
but they saw that be like well maybe the
the tam the total general market is just
college students the reason i think it's
interesting is that businesses and
founders expand in vision over time and
the the time when when a vision is a
visionary or founder has run out of
vision or run out of futures the moment
that the business dies or they sell it
because they just don't know what else
to do to grow it right what happens a
lot of times is that if we can if we can
contin you know continue to increase and
eat up the the total adjustable market
that we have defined for ourselves and
our business a lot of times adjacent you
know or adjacent markets or silos all of
a sudden become more and more attractive
we find out that there's a lot of
similarities or that we find out there's
another need and then we can branch into
yet another silo now if you're like i
that's the exact decision i did and i
went from a hundred thousand to two
hundred thousand a year no that was dumb
like that's not that's not the point of
this like you could you could just scale
one avatar to probably you know 100
million a year before doing that that's
not the point the point is that you know
on a long enough time horizon businesses
also through mergers and acquisition
things like that they can buy up other
companies that are adjacent close to
them et cetera and expand the total
market they have which is why i don't
necessarily think of it on a long term
time horizon but i do think about it on
a short-term time rise and so if i'm
looking at like the next three to five
years then i may be like okay we're not
going to change avatars next three to
five years but do i think that this
thing over the next 20 years could eat
up more and more of the pie by expanding
who we're potentially serving if the
answer is yes then the original tam or
the current tam is not necessarily what
the future tam is going to be and so
that's why i don't see tam as as
valuable as i think it it is purported
to be if you're new to the channel
welcome you hopefully can think through
those three different opportunity kind
of vehicle frames in terms of like how
can i look at my tam in a way that
potentially could sell more customers
how can i increase the value versus the
cost of what it is that i'm delivering
and is there a way that i can enter a
space that is more unique or newer which
i can either do by going into the
clearly new spaces or by trying to
redefine what i'm doing in a new way
right and if we can do those things then
we increase what i would consider the
opportunity size of what we are pursuing
and then ultimately make more money all
right and so that's what i'm thinking
about when i'm looking at these
companies that we're you know
potentially investing time and money
into otherwise hope you have an amazing
day and i'll see you guys next vid bye